ja ich begrüße sie zur heutigen sitzung
in der wir uns mit david hume und
immanuel kant befassen werden aber bevor
wir auf diese denker zu sprechen kommen
möchte ich erst noch einen rückblick
geben nämlich eine zusammenfassung über
die letzte sitzung und der hatten wir es
wie sie wissen mit einem sehr wichtigen
philosophen zu tun nämlich mit niemand
geringerem als gottfried wilhelm leibniz
und sehen anhand seiner schönen frisur
dass dieser mann in der barockzeit
gelebt haben muss da waren nämlich
solche perücken mode und die barockzeit
heißt da war der rationalismus sehr
wichtig also eine philosophische
strömung die der vernunft den verstand
sehr viel bedeutung zugemessen hat auch
die logik der mathematik der geometrie
und wenn wir jetzt gleich noch auf ein
paar texte von leibnitz eingehen werden
sie das auch gleich merken dass die
geometrie und die mathematik und die
logik als alles rationalistische im
hintergrund seiner philosophie steht so
und wir hatten da natürlich so ein paar
leitfragen wie immer uns überlegt wie
verhalten sich essenz also wiesen und
existenz bei leibnitz zueinander
dann hatten wir uns gefragt nach dem
zusammenhang der modalitäten hatte die
existenz im zusammenhang zur
notwendigkeit und kontingenz die
kontingenz bedeutet es ist nicht
unmöglich aber nicht notwendig also
ziemlich ähnlich wie möglich bei
leibnitz und wie verhält sich der
begriff der möglichkeit zu dem der
virtualität das ist jetzt eine sehr
schwierige frage
vielleicht kommen wir dann noch ein
bisschen darauf zu sprechen die möchte
ich aber nur am rande stellen und dann
auch diese frage nach der methode habe
ich auch schon ein bisschen verraten
die methode ist natürlich bei leibnitz
die rationalistische also logik
geometrie
detektiv nennt man das auch also recht
schematisch und daneben wie immer die
frage wie verhält sich leibnitz existenz
begriff zu den bisher behandelten
wir wollen immer versuchen rückblicke
herzustellen bereits diskutierten
philosophen so das sind die fragen und
jetzt gehen wir noch mal hier auf dieses
diesen satz hat das zitat zu sprechen
kann manchmal zu sprechen er sagt jetzt
ein schlechthin notwendiges hat ist
derjenige der in identische setzte
aufgelöst werden kann oder dessen
gegenteil einen widerspruch einschließt
ich will die sache durch ein beispiel in
zahlen belegen und jetzt sehen sie
wieder hier das ist natürlich die
nationalistische methode er versucht
jetzt seine these seine metaphysik oder
ökologie wir kommen gleich nochmal auf
das verhältnis von ontologien metaphysik
zu sprechen wenn wir den quiz lösen
also versucht die durch zahlen also am
beispiel der mathematik versuchte das
darzulegen
eine zweier zahl werde ich jede zahl
nennen die cloud durch 2 dividiert
werden kann eine dreier zahl bzw 4 zahlt
die welche glatt durch drei bzw 4
debattiert werden kann und sofort jede
zahl aber wollen wir in die zahlen auf
lösbar verstehen die sie glatt
dividieren
ich sage demnach der satz die zwölf zahl
ist eine vielzahl ist schlechthin
notwendig weil er folgendermaßen in
identischer setzte aufgelöst werden kann
die zwölf zahl ist die zweier 6er zahl
und so weiter und so fort das brauchen
wir jetzt gar nicht lösen sie sehen
dieser satz ihr die zwölf zahl ist eine
vierer zahl
das ist für leibnitz einsatz der
notwendig ist er sagt schlechthin
notwendig dh nach der kategorisierung
von leibnitz wäre das ein essentieller
satz und kein existenzielles ist also
dieser satz zeigt nur was über einen
wesens bestimmung aus er hat die zwölfte
zahl ist eine vielzahl sie können sie es
auch so verstehen dass subjekt wir haben
hier von subjekt und prädikat gesprochen
die zwölf zahlen das subjekt und ist
eine vielzahl das prädikat
das prädikat vier vierer zahl oder auch
sie sind dem subjekt 12 enthalten also
analytisch enthalten wir können die
zwölf analysieren in eben dreimal die
vierer zahlen das ist praktisch ein
analytischer oder auch ein identischer
satz oder eben auch ein essential ersatz
bekommen da gleich noch ein bisschen
genauer darauf zu sprechen
diese notwendigkeit nenne ich deshalb
die metaphysische oder geometrische
schauen sie wieder hier geometrische
notwendigkeit hier orientiert sich
leibnitz nationalistisch an der
geometrie was diese notwendigkeit
entbehrt nenne ich zufällig was jedoch
einen widerspruch einschließt oder
dessen gegenteil notwendig ist das heißt
unmöglich das übrige nennt man möglich
in der zufälligen wahrheit und wenn hier
auch das prädikat tatsächlich im subjekt
ist gelangt man durch die unbegrenzte
fortgesetzt die auflösung jedes
beliebigen der beiden ausdrücke doch
niemals zu einem beweise oder seine
identität und nur bei dem und nur dem
das unendlich auf einmal begreifen gott
ist es vorbehalten zu erkennen wie das
eine im anderen ist und den vollendeten
grund a priori der zufälligkeit 1 zu
sehen was bei den geschöpfen durch die
erfahrung apostel juri ersetzte
also er sagt jetzt von diesen
analytischen setzen oder den essential
setzen müssen er kommt bei gleich noch
drauf die existentiellen sitze
unterscheiden oder die zufälligen
wahrheiten und jesus eben nicht so dass
wir das prädikat aus dem subjekt heraus
analysieren können wie wir es konnten
bei dem satz eine 12 zahl ist eine
vierer zahlen so geht das nicht so
einfach sagt weiter hieraus lernen wir
nun dass die einsätze auf die essenz die
anderen aber auf die existenz der dinge
gehen
sn sie alle sätze sind ohne zweifel die
die durch auflösung der ausdrücke
bewiesen werden können die nämlich
notwendige oder virtuell identisches
sind und deren gegensatz darum unmöglich
oder wird
wenn ein widerspruch ist und diese sind
von einer ewigen wahrheit und werden
nicht nur gelten solange die welt stehen
wird seien hätten auch gegolten wenn
gott die welt anders geschaffen hätte
also die schöpfung der welt ist nicht
notwendig so wie sie ist sie ist nur
kontingent die welt hätte auch anders
geschaffen werden können natürlich zeigt
jetzt leibnitz wurde sie aber nicht
warum das wird jetzt ein bisschen weiter
leibnitz sagt wir leben der besten aller
möglichen welten also es hat schon
seinen grund warum wir in dieser welt
und nicht in einer anderen leben also
essential sätze sind analytische setzen
die so eine geometrische notwendigkeit
hin sich schließen und davon müssen wir
jetzt im nächsten zitat die
existentiellen setzte unterscheiden die
sind auch zufällig ist setzte nämlich
deren wahrheit kann nicht so bestimmt
werden wie wir sind die beispiel der
zwölf zahlen die fehlerzahl konnten weil
diese sätze kontingents sind und nutzen
einer bestimmten zeit war sind also
bringt ein beispiel dass ich jetzt lebe
dass die sonne scheint ich habe letzte
mal das beispiel gehabt das kann man
heute auch wieder anführen
am dritten juni 2020 schien um 12 uhr
mittags die sonne in münchen
dieser satz ist wahr aber er ist nicht
notwendigerweise war das heißt es hätte
heute auch prinzipiell regnen können
oder die sonne nicht scheine können aus
dem subjekt nämlich münchen halter
geografische ort die zeit folgt nicht
dass es heute notwendigerweise regnen
musste zumindest folgt das nicht für
endliche geister wenn man jetzt
natürlich die gesamten gründe der welt
der existenz von anfang an durch schaut
also alle kausalen faktoren
dann könnte man schon sagen vom urknall
herkommend wenn wir alle kausalketten
seit dem urknall verfolgen dann musste
es irgendwie heute schon sonnig sein
aber das ist jetzt noch mal was anderes
also normalerweise sind existenzielle
setzte solche die nicht notwendigerweise
wir sind eben nur zufälligerweise es
hätte auch anders sein können sagt noch
ein beispiel auch wenn ich nämlich sage
dass die sonne in dieser stunde auf
unserer hemisphäre scheint weil ihre
bewegung bisher so gewesen ist wie deren
fortsetzung angenommen die sicherlich
erfolg so ist es doch und von dem nicht
notwendigen zwang zur fortsetzung zu
schweigen eine zufällige wahrheit dass
ihre bewegung früher ebenso gewesen sein
eine wahrheit deren grund wiederum zu
suchen wäre und nicht völlig angegeben
werden könnte außer aus der vollkommenen
kenntnis aller teile des universums die
doch alle geschaffenen fähigkeiten
übersteigt weil es keinen teil der
materie gibt die nicht wirklich in
andere unterteilt ist weshalb die teile
jedes beliebige körpers und wirklich
unendlich sind also leibnitz stellt
jetzt hier am ende auch die frage nach
dem kontinuum wenn die welt
kontinuierlich ist als sie sich immer
weiter differenzieren lässt die teilchen
dann kommen wir natürlich nie einem ende
an
und dann haben wir auch natürlich nie
den letzten grund weil wir immer weiter
analysieren können das heißt sie sehen
hier schon so ein bisschen eine bewegung
wie in der mathematik das nennt man
diesel ihm ethisch annäherung also
ernährt sich etwas einer sache an
auch dieser begriff der unendlichkeit
ist ja bei der differential gleichung
sehr wichtig wenn man so ein liebes
bildet und leibnitz hat diese
differenzial im rechnung auch mit newton
zusammen entwickelt aber sie sehen also
hier wird schwierig bei diesen
existenziellen wahrheiten anders als bei
den analytischen oder auch essential war
halten dass man jetzt kommt fast noch
ein bisschen zusammen als wir haben nach
leibnitz notwendige oder auch
essentielle setzte er sagt auch
wahrheiten und fertig gilt das prädikat
dieses satzes ist bereits im subjekt
analytisch enthalten so wie eben die
vierer zahl als subjekt als prädikat im
subjekt der zwölf zahl enthalten ist
ich kann eben zwölf analysieren in drei
mal vier beispiel kann man auch weiter
geben alle junggesellen sind
unverheiratet im begriff des
jugendlichen ist der begriff des
unverheirateten analytisch enthalten
das war das beispiel von leibnitz die
zwölfte zahl ist eine vielzahl und ich
denke auch so was die winkel zum dreieck
beträgt 180 grad oder so was was auf
geometrischen notwendigkeiten basiert
die man reduzieren kann auch deshalb
spitalgasse solche sachen auch die wären
solche notwendigen essential setzte
davon kann man jetzt unterscheiden die
kontingente an existenziellen sitze oder
auch existenziellen wahrheiten die
unterscheiden sich von dem zuvor
behandelten essential panik oder sitzen
und zwar insofern als sie das prädikat
nicht im subjekt analytisch enthalten
ist und das kann man auch hier wieder so
ein paar beispiele geben ein beispiel
hatte ich ja auch schon geben verwendet
auch leibnitz am dritten juni 2020 schon
um 12 uhr die sonne in münchen sie hätte
auch nicht scheinen müssen weiteres
beispiel war sie mir jetzt überlegt hat
aber darüber kann man auch noch mal
später diskutieren die titanic kenterte
an einem eisberg war es notwendig dass
die titanic an einem eis bild kennt dann
musste offensichtlich nicht als es liegt
nicht im wesen der titanic dass sie
diesen eisberg rahmen musste also hätte
ihn ja auch meiden können ja und was mir
auch noch eingefallen ist folgendes
beispiel oliver bierhoff schoss das
erste golden goal der fußballgeschichte
im jahr 1996 könnte man noch hinzufügen
es war nicht notwendig dass ihr das
gemacht hat er hätte es auch verfehlen
könnten also zum beispiel solche sätze
wie diese person tat dies zu dieser
uhrzeit an diesem ort die person hätte
das auch wo ganz anders machen können
das liegt nicht im begriff diese person
enthalten dass sie das oder das gemacht
hat weil es nur eine möglichkeit für sie
bedeutet aber nicht nur notwendigkeiten
also das wesen von universum besteht
nicht darin dass er das golden goal
geschossen hat auch wenn manche person
natürlich dann reduziert werden auch
bestimmte ereignisse und man bestimmte
handlung von ihnen oder ereignisse
untrennbar mit ihnen verbindet das dann
aber eher was psychologisches was mit
unserer assoziation zu tun hat
hier geht es jetzt wirklich um eine
begriffliche konzeptuelle bestimmung
ja das ist eben jetzt die
zusammenfassung gewesen und ich will
auch die zuschauer auf die lowcost
animieren bei dem existenz quiz
mitzumachen denn selbst mal zu lösen
oder das quiz sagt man ja glaube ich
hier und es gibt zehn fragen und sie
bekommen eine automatische auflösung und
ich werde auch dann am ende unten jetzt
in der beschreibung einen link dann rein
machen zu dem quiz und dann können sie
selbst mal schauen wie gut sie sich mit
den themen die existenz auskennen